I max is a great tool to make people
live in the shoes of the main character
and not let them escape are you okay
this is such a visually beautiful film I
want to see it in IMAX there's so many
gigantic big wide frames there's also a
lot of scary stuff kind of put into
places that you wouldn't expect so I
feel like seeing it on the big screen is
gonna be really cool for an audience
with IMAX it's not just about visuals I
take a fiendish Glee in torturing people
would say hunt when you're watching a
film where are you Lee and I spoke a lot
about trying to kind of embed Adrian so
he was sort of this presence that you
felt and I think that he's done that
through sound breath where you would
never hear it unless you're really
listening but it adds attention to it
and then it's an IMAX so it's amplified
I mean the movie doesn't ever let up I
genuinely was really quite terrified
watching it and I know what happens
surprised
whenever anyone directs a film they
wanted to be seen in the best way
possible so I would encourage people to
get out and see at night nights it's
gonna be quite something quite the
experience
you
you